well this speech the president on the
record said that it was going to be
extremely extraordinarily low-key those
were his words that he put on the record
today at the lunch with anchors
including myself John Roberts is
reporting tonight that the president
will announce that he is awarding the
Presidential Medal of Freedom to Rush
Limbaugh during tonight's State of the
Union speech we also understand that
rush limbaugh may be in attendance
tonight the radio talk show host of
course announcing this week that he's
fighting advanced lung cancer that's one
of the elements of this speech what else
are we looking for let's bring in our
panel panel Matthew cotton Eddie again
founding editor of the Washington free
beacon moralizing national political
correspondent of National Public Radio
and Susan frito chief congressional
correspondent for the Washington
Examiner Susan well that's that's pretty
big news to have Rush Limbaugh ComNet
the announcement and he had cancer was
just so devastating for tens of million
millions of people who are his fans and
have been following him for decades and
he kind of defined the conservative
movement after Ronald Reagan so he's
just a big figure in the conservative
movement so the president will really be
reaching a lot of his base by making
this announcement so soon after we heard
this terrible news about Rush Limbaugh I
think that's
Limbaugh obviously a huge supporter of
the President and has always had his
back even in the most controversial of
times that's right now he's not you know
not everybody has supported the
president but amongst the conservatives
cuz you know we have the never Trump
movement he who keep pretty much stayed
onboard with him even while he was
running and there were other candidates
in the race till now he has been a
staunch supporter and a defender of him
during this whole impeachment process
more the other thing that usually state
of the unions are are a laundry list of
things to do last year the speech was
structured a little differently had kind
of wove a lot of stories in there the
president I think we'll use it to tout
accomplishments that he sees ahead of
this electric this is like a curtain
raiser for his re-election campaign it's
not a rally he says it's gonna be very
low-key and it's gonna be very long -
that's very an untrim peon recipe you
know he likes to be really entertaining
but this is a chance biggest audience
he's going to get all year to tout
accomplishments to talk about the
economy to talk about black and Hispanic
unemployment rates being low to talk
about all the things he's gotten done I
don't think this is a president who has
a tremendously long legislative agenda
he'll talk about things he'll do if he
gets reelected
maybe middle-class tax cuts but I think
he wants to tout his accomplishments he
wants to tell the positive story of his
tenure but Matthew the image here of a
president who has been impeached the
trial is not over the acquittal likely
is going to come tomorrow standing in
the well of the house with lawmakers
some of them who will be voting on his
acquittal or conviction the next day
that's right but I think in the minds of
many in Washington and probably the
public of large impeachment is receding
fast in the rearview mirror this is
Trump's morning in America moment the
camp the State of the Union is the
beginning of a campaign you're always
big campaign speeches to frame the
debate
I'm sure you'll hear talk about how
America will never be a socialist
country the economy booming Trump
acquitted tomorrow this is the wind does
that his back at precisely the moment he
needs it to be we talked a little bit
about the Gallup poll but that that
really did opens Moz here in Washington
that 49% approval and Republicans at 53
percent but if you look at the RCP
average this is across the board recent
polls approval 45 roughly and the
economy this is really where all of the
polls matchup is is kind of touting the
success that the administration has had
on this front and it's the people who
Democrats might want to target most in
this upcoming election the low wage
earners there their wages are growing
faster than anybody's and these are the
people who we always hear Democrats
saying the economy's not the booming
economies not reaching these people well
it is it's also reaching minorities and
their if they're running out of room to
target Trump so he can really tout that
tonight in his speech he's really can
really be a victory lap for her expect
that close I think about
african-americans you know you saw the
ad in the Super Bowl about the first
step and the judicial reform but that
wasn't aimed at african-americans that
was also aimed at suburban women in
particular who don't like some of the
racially tinged attacks that he's made
that ad was to create a permission
structure just like the ad in the world
series that said you might not like him
you might even hate him he's not mr.
nice guy I think was the tagline for
that ad but look what he's done for you
you're better off than you were four
years ago
Trump has an opportunity to expand his
base and the way to do that is by
targeting black and Hispanic men which I
think that ad also helped with all right
we shall see Thank You panel with